got a chance to speak to judd apatow
this was Wednesday after the show we
taped an interview he's got a new movie
it's on demand starting today and it
stars Pete Davidson Marisa Tomei and the
great comedian bill burr it's called the
king of Staten Island and here is Judd
Apatow the writer director producer of
the movie hello how are you
I'm well how are you sir look at that
hair here oh my god let yourself go
if they knew castaway - I think you're
ready ok you can show some cleavage I'm
alright with that I'm taping it so I'm
ready if you are
I mean you have daughters your wife
didn't anybody help you today no one
helps me
no one cares how I looked at I was
wondering about this comedian arted yeah
yes you're ready to start and three
three two writer producer director
comedian if I said you can only have one
title yes which one I guess writer I
guess it all starts there I'll say that
wait why not comedian I mean as close as
well but with comedian you know I get
comedian but with writer it's connected
to a bunch of other things is that it's
comedian comedian that's what you how
often do you get a neighbor who wants to
pitch something to you or try to be
funny to you it's pretty rare because I
think it takes some courage to pitch a
funny joke or movie idea and usually
when somebody does it does not go well I
used to do this thing on the stage where
I would say to the crowd I will listen
to your pitches for movies and I would
bring three people onstage and I would
say pitch me your movie ideas and they
were always in the same no one ever had
a good one they were all crazy but down
balaam that would be a great show I
would love to see you on
stage with people doing their pitches I
I think we just made a show I think we
did really nice I think did I just pitch
you a show that got greenlit
I think it says greenlit that means it's
not a sweatsuit
it's just a top I don't have pants to go
along with it I think this is why
comedians hang out with comedians judge
because you want to you don't want to
hear other people try to be funny
yes like non funny people comedians like
to hang out with funny people do you
think that's that's fair I think that's
true it's rare that a good comedian
wants to hang out with a terrible
unfunny comedian that's why you see like
groups of comedians who hang out
together because they so enjoy a good
joke that if someone's really not good
at hanging and being funny
they really exclude them it's brutal
Sandler is really good at that it's kind
of a generous laugh I don't know if it's
real but when he hangs with us he's
really good at just sort of a fake
laughter I would say this he must find
you funny he wants you around I think
that's real after I think that's due to
sports jut not comedy oh you think he
like he tolerates you trying to be funny
you have fun sport yeah with you yeah
this is possible this this you may have
you may have figured something out right
there yeah unfortunately all right how
long does it take before you have the
idea of this movie the king of Staten
Island before you actually start writing
a script well Pete Davidson and I met
when we were doing trainwreck he did a
cameo and after his cameo Bill Hader
liked him so much he recommended him to
learn Michaels and he got Saturday Night
Live this is in 2014
six years ago so we've been working on
it since then we work on a different
movie I gave him an idea for a movie to
write that turned out to be a terrible
idea and he probably wasted two years on
a bad goofy idea and then we were like I
guess we should think of a better idea
and then slowly we started talking about
doing something much more personal that
came from his life yeah because it's not
loose
based on his life it's based on his life
from what I've read about Pete well you
Pete his father was a firefighter who
died on 9/11 and that was very traumatic
he was 7 years old when that happened
and we talked about creating a fictional
story that could get to all the real
emotions and and how it affected his
family so you know in the movie he plays
a slacker pothead who's going nowhere in
life and in real life you know pizza guy
who was on Saturday Night Live by the
time he was 20 so there are big
differences but within the story you get
to a lot of deep emotional stuff yeah
and you get that dead father joke out of
the way or early in the movie but was
that by design like let's let's take it
out of the room here I think that it
happened instinctually Ricky Velez was a
great comedian who is a friend of Pete's
was in a scene early in the in the movie
and we knew we want to just show that
his friends think it's okay to joke
about the fact that his dad is dead
because obviously Pete's character is
lying he isn't over it but he tells them
he's over it and then Ricky improvised
you know knock knock who's there not
your dad but I also think he only had
the courage to improvise that jokey
because he's one of Pete's best friends
and he knew that that is the kind of
joke that they would tell with each
other cuz only your closest friends
would go that dark the movie is the king
of Staten Island we're talking to a Judd
Apatow the producer writer director
comedian who joins us on the program I
all interesting the reaction to bill
burr who plays Marissa Tomei Marissa
Tomei is Pete Davidson's mom and Bill
burr is a firefighter who starts dating
her and then people's reaction was God
bill burrs good at being serious and I
said well if you think about the premise
of stand-up comedy it is really based on
drama in a comedians life and darkness
you just have the ability comedians have
the ability to make it funny
so why wouldn't you know Sandler in
uncut gems people like I didn't know
could be Robin Williams the same way
that ability to we they deal with drama
they just make their drama funny for us
I thought burr was really really really
good yes he is a great actor and a big
hearted guy so you know something like
that it was opinionated and has that
bluster and then when you slowly see his
heart and you see how much he cares
about Pete it's very moving and we were
all blown away by his performance and at
the same time you know we loved his
stand-up he's like a fierce ridiculously
legendary comedian what's the movie you
wish people ask you more about I'm
always about walk hard
I love walk hard john c reilly it was a
parody of walk the line and ray and
music biopics and what's funny is after
the movie about Queen came out there
were a lot of articles about walk art
but basically said this movie is doing
all the tropes and we're in walk hard
and some articles like wait a second I
think walk hard might be such a silly
movie it's it really makes me laugh it's
just I don't do that many movies that
are just like airplane type joke fests
and every time it's on it's the only one
of the movies I've worked on but I will
watch a lot of it because there's a lot
of little jokes that make me laugh a lot
then there's people like Eddie Vedder
and Jack white and Jackson Browne and
goofy but when you know you have
something special how deep into the
process sometimes when you're shooting
you feel like I think it's happening I
feel I feel like this is coming together
but when you really know is I ask the
editors every day to send me the cuts of
what they edited that day so while I'm
shooting I get links to the scenes from
earlier in the week and usually you
could just tell if there's chemistry
between all of the actors and actresses
and if and sometimes some of the scenes
are great and you're like oh my god I
think you know Carell getting his chest
waxed is really fun because you don't
know till you get it together
I mean crazy funny and you get very
excited
that improv in any way when Carell gets
waxed in 40 year virgin I mean it's all
improvised we put four cameras on him
and we just waxed him and the funny
thing is we we looked for an actress who
also was a professional hair waxer so we
hired this woman to do it and I think
she lied and was not a professional hair
waxer because she put some of the wax
over his nipple and I think she came
like that close to tearing off his
nipple I mean he was covered in blood by
but you had all of those comedians with
cameos like bringing all of those people
together and making them shine has to be
I don't know the challenge of doing that
you know it's less challenging when
they're great there's always people that
you love who haven't had giant
opportunities yet you know at that time
you know we knew Jane Lynch from Best in
Show
and we thought well she's it's funny as
human beings get and Craig Robinson just
started on the office only I think maybe
six episodes had aired at that point
Mindy Kaling was on the office as well
and you know Kevin Hart did a small part
in the 40 old virgin Romany Malco as
Jonah Hill Jonah Hill has a little part
so we just picked people that crack us
up and that we love and then we hope
they have a great moment and in that
movie weirdly so many of them really
grabbed their moment but can you write
around and I don't know the process so
if I sound ignorant then correct me but
can you write around four or five really
great moments like bridesmaids when you
have Maya out there with a wedding dress
and she's you know has to use the
bathroom like can you can you write
around that and then you find another
scene that you write around like three
or four those and you can make a movie
out of that or is that maybe stripping
this down too much well I'd like to look
at it like I'm trying to make a great
dramatic movie and if I if I can get the
drama to work then I can find a way to
make it funny I think if you start with
the funny stuff it's usually bad and
it's gonna feel the story and the
emotions just jammed in later we've all
seen those movies where people are just
going nuts
is not much of a story and I think those
are much harder to get to work than if
you're really emotionally invested in
something favorite comedy that you watch
I own it
well when I was growing up I loved the
jerk as a kid but you idolized Steve
Martin right yes I mean I talked like
him for years as a child and the jerk
was like my dream because I was a big
fan of his and then suddenly they're
like oh he's gonna make a movie and then
to me the jerk was my dream of what that
movie could possibly be so that was a
big movie for me when I was a kid and
then I think as a kid Fast Times at
Ridgemont High was very inspirational
because it was both really funny but had
a lot of grounded elements in it there's
a lot of credibility to it as well
yeah you're trying to in it's weird how
those things kind of form what you think
humor is because when I was growing up I
always thought well Bill Murray is funny
and so I gravitated towards that sense
of humor and then Robin Williams came
along and I went no he's too
over-the-top he's got to be like Bill
Murray and I don't know if if you
approach things in a well Steve Martin
was a cerebral way of looking at comedy
well there were people I thought were
funny that I thought I don't know how to
be funny like that so I would see people
like Paul Reiser and Jerry Seinfeld and
Jay Leno and think I guess I'm kind of
like those guys I'm from Long Island I
could relate and then there were people
I really worshiped you have like all the
Monty Python people and Steve Martin or
John Belushi and I would think well
they're great but I don't think I'm
funny in the way that they're funny I'm
different I couldn't pull that off you
always do cameos or at least there's
always small cameos there is this year
Alfred Hitchcock approach where you're
gonna be in there and we have to spot
you a cab driver or whatever it might be
I haven't done that you know I was in
the disaster artist they asked me to
play like that like a nasty producer who
yelled at James Franco in the movie and
I was like okay I could do that like
jerk Hollywood producer and I did the
scene and then I saw
the movie in the credits it said Judd
Apatow as himself when you were first
pitch LeBron mm-hmm what was your
reaction to how do I make this work how
do I make him look good when we were
portraying on the draft a me you know
was riding Bill Hader as a sports
medicine doctor and then the idea came
up what if his best friend is a gigantic
star athlete and immediately
LeBron's name came up with no thought
that that was possible usually you start
with LeBron and then you just keep you
know going down and down he goes like 80
people to get to whatever you can get
bill said you just said SNL and I think
he had a really good time let's ask him
and we went to a Laker game villain I
and then we said hi to him afterwards
and the next day we went to lunch with
him and I always remember how exhausted
he seemed after the game it's the next
day
and I thought wow they really leave it
all on the floor and then his teammates
kept walking up and saying hello at the
restaurant in the hotel and they all
seemed exhausted and and I thought man
it's a hard job you know they're they're
recovering right now and then we told
him the joke like you're the Bruno Kirby
and When Harry Met Sally and he just
thought that was hysterical but he's the
best friend and the joke is that he
cares that he's really tracking and
really cares and he was hysterical I
mean he's a very talented actor and he
has got a great sense of humor that
wasn't like me spoon-feeding anything
that was genuinely him being riotously
funny the movie is the king of Staten
Island starring Pete Davidson it will be
available on demand by the way Marissa
Tomei spectacular nice casting they're
always always know you can air her then
people think you're a good director
Friday June 12th it will be available
it's the king of Staten Island good luck
with a movie Judd it's always great to
talk to you
and I just want to let you know that I
do see other directors in perdu
behind Sandler's back so I don't need to
be tied to the Sandler franchise I'm
just saying this is an offer this is
just an announcement that's all this is
just it just it is one of those bars you
know when like well I did ask Sandler
when I died do you think of the Academy
Awards I get up there on the in memoriam
I think I'm in a teen movies so far like
what is the cutoff point for in memoriam
I think James Dean was in three Judd
that's it I think you should tell them
now I expect that I'm gonna send him a
good picture of me right now just so
they can use that hey I love the movie I
thought it was wonderful a lot of
laugh-out-loud moments and thank you and
mod did great yes your daughter did very
proud yes yeah it should be thank you
Judd all right thank you see that that's
Judd Apatow it's the king of Staten
Island